15 وزيرا جديدا فهل بهم الرئيس التركي
اردوغان تعديلاته الحكوميه في فترته
الرئاسيه الجديده خطوه تظهر تغييرات كبيره
في سياساته فتره مجدا جديده للجمهوريه
التركيه وعاد بها في خطاب التنصيب هذه
الفتره بدات باسماء بارزه يراهن عليها
اردوغان الاستعاده تفوقه خارجيا وداخليا
تركيا
تم قبول مشروعنا الخاص باستكمال بناء
تركيا في القرن الجديد من قبل امتنا في
الرابع عشر من مايو
لقد اعطى شعبنا الاغلبيه في البرلمان اولا
للتحالف الشعب بثلاثمائه وثلاثه وعشرين
نائبا ثم اعطى الرئاسه لي باكثر من 52% من
الاصوات قائلا لندع الاستقرار يستمر وندع
تركيا تنمو لخمس سنوات اخرى
استبدل اردوغان جميع اعضاء حكومته
باستثناء وزير الصحه فخر الديناقوجا ووزير
الثقافه والسياحه محمد نوري ارسوئي قطاعه
شهد التطورا ملحوظا خلال السنوات الاخيره
ستكون معالجه المشاكل الاقتصاديه على راسي
اولويات اردوغان حيث بلغ التضخم
43.7% بسبب السياسه غير التقليديه
المتمثله في خفض اسعار الفائده لتحفيز
النمو لذا جاء تعيين تعيين محمد الشمشك في
منصبي وزير الخزانه والماليه ليعكس نيه
اردوغان تغيير سياسته الاقتصاديه التي
كانت دائما معارضه لرفع قيمه الفائده
وزاره الخارجيه ذهبت اليهاكان فيدان رئيس
وكاله الاستخبارات التركيه منذ عام 2010
هو دبلوماسيه الظل وكاتم اسرار اردوغان
بحسب وصف الاخير
جهدي من اجل وحده اراضي وان يرفاهيه
دولتنا وامتنا ساستمر في العمل نحو رؤيه
السياسه الخارجيه الوطنيه القائمه على
استقرار دولتنا عن اي تاثير خارجي وسياده
مطلقه لامتنا
ما وزاره الداخليه فاستبدل القومي سليمان
سويلو بوالي اسطنبول علي ييرلكايا المطلع
على ملف مكافحه الارهاب منذ كان واليا في
ولايات الشرق حيث المواجهات مع مقاتلي حزب
العمال الكردستاني اما وزاره الدفاع
فاستمرت سياسه ما بعد محاوله الانقلاب في
2016 ان يكون الوزير من قاده الجيش فجاء
تعيين رئيس الاركان يشار جولر خلفا
لهالوسي اكار
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات